hello there and good morning it is 7 00
am now she's been in office for less
than 48 hours and the new prime minister
will unveil today a long-awaited plan to
help households and businesses deal with
the soaring cost of energy this trust is
expected to freeze household bills at
about two and a half thousand pounds at
a likely cost of more than 100 billion
pounds but she has rejected the idea of
using a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies profits to fund the package
and is expected to be paid for instead
by extra borrowing so will it be enough
to help the millions of families and
businesses already struggling with the
spiraling cost of living i'll put this
to the new secretary of state for
leveling up housing and communities
simon clark when he joins us in just a
few moments time it is thursday the 8th
of september
liz trust promises immediate action to
tackle the energy crisis as she sets out
her emergency plan to help families and
businesses
the new prime minister is expected to
announce a freeze on energy bills but
she's rejected the idea of a winful tax
on oil and gas companies to pay for it
the final suspect in the fatal mass
stabbings in canada has died in custody
after his car was forced from the road
by police
this evening our province is breathing a
collective sigh of relief
as miles sanderson is no longer at large
the body of a british aid worker
captured by russian-backed separatists
in ukraine is returned with what are
described as signs of possible torture
pulling down the soviet flag ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski claims
progress in his country's
counter-offensive against russian forces
and two princes and a princess start a
new school george louis and charlotte
head to class together from their new
home in windsor
and also this morning
shot through the neck in afghanistan at
the age of 24 i'll speak to a former
special forces soldier toby gutteridge
about the day his life changed forever
hi guys you know how proud i am of my
superpower so i'm very excited to tell
you today my huge news in bsl
so here goes
and i'll speak to love island's first
deaf contestant tasha guri about the
work that she's doing to encourage
people to learn british sign language
[Music]
hello and good morning the new prime
minister will announce her multi-billion
pound plan to help households and
businesses with storing energy bills
later on this morning now in a statement
to parliament liz trust is due to unveil
a package of emergency measures for
england scotland and wales to support
people through the crisis she's also
expected to set out plans to increase
the uk's domestic energy supply now that
could mean reversing a ban on fracking
and giving the go-ahead to more drilling
in the north sea well let's start with
what we can expect to hear from mrs
announcement later on first the current
situation now the energy price cap for
households is
1971 pounds right now that's set to go
up by 80 percent from october to an
average of
3549 pounds a year and that cost is
expected to continue rising in 2023
possibly above 5000 pounds now
government sources told sky news that
this trusts will announce a freeze on
household energy bills at around two and
a half thousand pounds part of this will
be covered by a 400 pound grant for each
household now that was announced by the
government back in may that rebate plus
some extra adjustments will take the
actual cost of typical household bills
down to around two and a half thousand
pounds closer to their current level now
it's understood the package will cost
around 100 billion pounds but that is
dependent of course on the price of
wholesale gas so how would it all be
paid for well this trust has rejected
the idea of a windfall tax on the
profits of oil and gas companies
expected that the treasury will fund it
through government borrowing eventually
paid through general taxation
well let's speak now to the new leveling
up housing and communities secretary
simon clark previously chief secretary
of the treasury mr clark love you to
have you with us good morning your time
this morning it's going to be a busy day
for you guys of course of this new
administration how far off were we with
our prediction of the way that this
package is going to work well as you'd
expect i can't preempt the prime
minister's announcement today but what
you're absolutely right in saying is
that the government is going to be
taking meaningful action to address the
concerns which viewers will be feeling
and which of course aren't restricted to
family finances they affect businesses
as well
so that we can have certainty for the
country about what we're going to do
over the course of the winter ahead we
all know that
as a consequence of what putin has done
in ukraine and his attempt to weaponize
uh particularly gas as a
as a way of trying to break the west
resolve in terms of standing up for
democracy
that there are really tumultuous events
in the energy markets we need to provide
a solution which doesn't just address
this in a way which means that we keep
coming back to it but which provides a
lasting framework for how we're going to
sort this uh for people over the months
ahead now just the proposals because i i
respect that you you will not tell us
what the plans are you want to prove to
the prime minister but just the
proposals have led to some turmoil in
the markets the pound's at its lowest
level since 1985. i mean it's not the
market's telling you that whatever
you're proposing is going to be really
damaging and dangerous to the economy
well we all obviously would never want
to find ourselves in this situation and
there's there's no question that you
know this is the latest in a series of
quite extraordinary interventions that
the government has had to make to
support uh families and you know which
obviously reflect our absolute
determination to do the right thing uh
for the british people but let's be
clear if we fail to act if we don't uh
protect the economy against the shock of
the size and scale that we're talking
about then there's going to be enormous
economic damage uh in any event so the
hardship that the not just the october
price cap but the forecast january and
then april iterations would would cause
would be enormous and we're already
hearing from businesses and this is
something i was obviously hearing in my
former treasury role about the the deep
concerns they have about their energy
bills and so you know we could have
anticipated i think a huge amount of
damage to the economy had this uh had
this rise gone ahead unchecked so you're
balancing frankly two uh very
challenging things
in these circumstances i think the
country will say and i think markets
will respect that this is the most
sensible thing to do well i mean respect
is one thing but their reaction is
another and of course the markets will
behave as they think is is uh in their
best interests and it would seem as if
economists people who are doing these
kind of forecasting don't trust this
plan that's coming forward well if you
look at the uh the uk's most recent
round of uh of debt issuance you know
that was well covered uh you know there
was there was much more demand for our
for our debt than was needed to uh cover
the latest auction we're paying around
three percent uh for uh for our our debt
that's that's a perfectly sustainable
level the uk is obviously a very stable
very strong economy subject you know to
a very clear regulatory system and the
rule of law we are a safe bet and a safe
haven as we always are frankly in these
kind of situations and the government is
clear that a fiscally responsible
approach sits at the heart of our plans
but we we cannot fail to respond to the
magnitude at the moment this trust is
clear that you know as prime minister
her first priority this week is to is to
provide that certainty and i think you
know this is something which
notwithstanding the fact it's difficult
it's bold it's brave we have to do
because the country can't really think
about anything else until we've done
this
well with the idea of debt in mind then
the prime minister ruled out the idea of
expanding the windfall tax um
stuck with a plan on corporation tax as
well so in the future that debt burden
is going to be much much higher isn't it
well you know as as with the financial
crisis in 2008 and as with the kova
situation the government has to respond
to these major crises and then uh deal
with the deal with the consequences in a
measured way over over time but the
prime minister is rightly clear that we
cannot keep on with the mindset that we
can tax our way to growth we can't keep
doing that we need these oil and gas
companies to be focusing on more
extraction an extraction of north sea
gas is up 26 compared to this time last
year which is fantastic we need to see a
lot more of that because the reality is
energy independence is the lasting
solution to the situation we are in and
we can never again and this is the wider
context of this strategy find ourselves
in a situation where we are reliant on
others for the things that we need we've
got to get much closer to
self-sufficiency these companies are
absolutely critical to that happening
and happening at the pace we need i mean
self-sufficiency is of course what
everyone will want but you were chief
secretary of the treasury so kirsten
were quite a treasury figure yesterday
said 170 billion pounds in excess
profits is going to be made by energy uh
energy companies might i mean is that
are those correct figures look the the
reality is that if companies are making
large profits then of course they will
also be paying large amounts in tax to
the exchequer and there's already a
windfall tax which was introduced
earlier this year and critically it's
worth remembering that oil and gas
companies pay double the main rate of
corporation tax they pay 40 p in the
pound compared to 19p as the main rate
so it's not as though they don't pay
their fair share of taxation but these
are the people who are going to be
delivering that next generation of
nausea oil and gas investment we've got
all of these fields that we frankly need
to bring on stream as quickly as
possible
labour will always say because it's in
their dna the solution is to tax tax tax
actually what we need is to invest and
to grow this is how we do that yeah i
mean let's stick with 170 billion you
haven't said those figures are wrong so
that is that is a correct estimate well
no i'm not going to confirm or deny uh
figures which i i i said today you
didn't recognize those specific figures
okay look there's a lot of money that
could be got from taxing these oil and
gas companies more and you're deciding
the government is deciding to put all
that money onto the country's credit
card there was a time when that was seen
as fiscally responsible the conservative
government said that was fiscally what
now is it what we do is we is we fix the
roof when the sun is shining the sun is
conspicuously not shining right now this
is a global storm and the uk is uh you
know like the rest of the west having to
react to events which are you know not
of our making so the the you know the
invasion of ukraine hard on the heels of
the uh the kovic crisis have obviously
prompted us to have to do some dramatic
and extraordinary things but we can do
those things because frankly we spent
the last 10 years repairing the damage
of the 08 financial crash and that's why
what george osborne did what philip
hammond did mattered so much because
that fiscal consolidation has given us
the space
to do what is required in the teeth of
an emergency that's why frankly
conservative economics makes sense so
that you have no concerns about all this
borrowing it's going to be loaded onto
future generations my children's general
i mean look i mean i you know we are all
very conscious of this and you know i i
absolutely believe that the state should
live within its means uh you know
whenever possible but you have to also
balance what we're seeking to do here
for the real economy in the near term
against that against that challenge
we're comfortable that this is the right
approach critically what we cannot do is
just allow this situation to play out
without a decisive intervention i think
what we're seeing from liz truss's
government is early decisive
intervention which will provide a
lasting framework critically so we're
not keeping coming back to those
intervals it's not like you've just
wanted a general election you were in
government for two months this could
have come well in the summer it couldn't
because there wasn't there wasn't a
government with a mandate to do this and
i'm afraid as a result of the situation
we faced over the summer yeah we've only
now actually got the challenge
so you could have done something earlier
in the summer i'm afraid to say we we
weren't in the position to do that we
are now we're acting today before that
price cut comes in let's just move on to
your new brief that's leveling up and
and housing minster just what is
leveling up and what does it mean to you
what is something leveling up is the uh
delivering of opportunity to all parts
of the country and the you know the
realities i represent a uh constituency
up on t side in the northeast and you
know the communities i represent are
proud are passionate about uh you know
their lives but you know let's be clear
the opportunity in places like loftus or
middlesbrough is not the same as it
would be here in westminster and we have
got to close that gap we've got to close
it through infrastructure investment
we've got to close it above all through
economic growth and the delivery of more
enterprise more uh frankly more economic
opportunity is is the is the absolute
key to leveling up and that's what i'm
determined to help deliver opportunities
delivered through fracking in people's
neighborhoods i mean we know how
unpopular fracking is with many
communities well we have to look at all
forms of energy extraction and this
again leads us into the discussion that
the prime minister will be opening up
as part of her announcement uh today but
look if we want energy sufficient so we
have to look at every source including
clearly new nuclear more renewables and
there's you know fantastic news uh going
on with uh with technologies like
offshore wind while the price just keeps
falling but yeah we also ought to look
at technologies like fracking we have to
do so in the most sensitive possible way
with community consent at the absolute
heart of our policies but there is a
balanced approach to this question the
net zero commitment that the government
has made by 2050 is critical it's
something that i uh helped to push for
when i was
about venture it's something which i
passionately believe unlocks frankly the
greatest energy security as well as
economic economic opportunity but in the
near term we need all kinds of gas
there's a transition fuel and that's
something our prime minister will be
saying more about later today move on to
just one last thing the new cabinet is
you're a new member of this cabinet
you're in the old one as well but
we'll stick with this new cabinet now
why did you vote against uh expanding
same-sex marriage to northern ireland in
2019. i made that choice because uh
candidly i believe in devolution and the
uh the situation we faced in 2019 was
that we didn't have a functioning
assembly in storm and i don't believe uh
that as a english mp it's really my
prerogative to be voting on social
issues in northern ireland which are
properly a matter for the devolved
assembly uh in in northern ireland
elected by the people of northern
ireland where clearly there are
different cultural and social uh
conditions to in the rest of the uk i
simply believe uh and i stand by my
decision that it wasn't for me to tell
others how to live their lives i
personally am all in favor of same-sex
marriage and i'm you know thrilled that
it's in place in england i've got many
many friends who live happily uh in
same-sex marriages but it isn't for me
to tell other people how to live their
lives in in parts of the country where
devolution is in place i believed at the
time and i think you know i completely
stand by that that it it was right that
they should have that that that say over
of what happened
but from politicians accountable to them
okay i mean it's very clear answer i
appreciate that
um
just fine let's go back to fracking as
well in the net zero commitment so if
you do expand fracking um more
extraction of gas from from beneath the
earth how are we going to meet those net
zero commitments well we're absolutely
clear that net zero as i say sits at the
heart of our policies and you know we've
got to use gases
yeah by 2050 absolutely there is no
resilient for that commitment we've just
got you know wonderful new advances like
the hornet c2 uh offshore wind uh uh
farm which is the largest i think in in
europe and that's going to power 1.3
million homes that's just gone live
we've got the big decision which has
just been taken on sizewell uh c the new
nuclear power station but you know we we
cannot avoid the reality that gas from
russia has underpinned not just uh
britain but europe's wider energy
strategy
that dependence has left us desperately
vulnerable it has to end now and in the
in the interim uh we have to make sure
that we're using all available sources
of domestic fuel i think the public
would think that's the only sensible
thing to do hey simon clark really
appreciate your time this morning thank
you thank you busy day for you thank you
all right
now as the prime minister plans to
tackle the energy crisis of course that
story is featuring on the front page of
most of this morning's newspapers we'll
start with the front page of the times
which reports on what it says will be a
150
billion pound scheme to freeze energy
bills for two years
the guardian now which suggests that liz
trust has planned a thought to involve a
cap of two and a half thousand pounds
until 2024 is an attempt to help bring
about unity within the conservative
party
the mirror welcomes news of the
intervention pointing out mistrust is
against the idea of a windfall tax as we
just heard from simon clark that
the daily mail leads with the pm's
prospective policy calling it liz's
energy revolution
while the express says that she wants to
be seen as a woman of action
now still to come on the program at 20
to eight we'll be joined by tim farren
the lib dems rural affairs spokesperson
and we're going to speak to the shadow
climate secretary ed miliband as we get
ready for the new prime minister to
unveil her plans to deal with the energy
crisis
the resolution foundation is warning
that disposable household income is set
to plummet by 10 this year i'll be
speaking to their chief economist
now many people around the country are
already struggling to make ends meet
with food banks across the uk reporting
an increased need for their services
well let's bring in sabbah chowdhury
who's joining us from a food bank in
east london good morning to you sabha
nice to see you so just tell us
how are the guys doing there and how
much of an increase in demand have they
been seeing
good morning well it's been uh rather
significant i was just speaking
to the reverend reverend a journey who's
behind me now preparing some sandwiches
and she's saying that over the past uh
few months or so they have seen an
increase in the number of ordinary
people who have been coming
to this church the emanuel parish
church here in east london to receive
food parcels and i'll just bring you
over here she's preparing some tuna
sandwiches some food parcels for
individuals who will be coming
later uh reverend adjourney thank you so
much for joining us on sky news tell me
a little bit about what it is that
you're doing and who it is that you guys
here are aiming to help yes well every
thursday morning we come to the church
and we um make sandwiches and food
parcels we pack all foods that we have
we get donated from the community and be
business people our local people and we
make up food parcels and hand it out to
the homeless or people who are finding
it difficult to cope with the cost of
living and we have seen an increase and
intake of people coming in especially
since the prices have gone through the
roof and they complain to us that
they're unable to cope so we hand out
food parcels to them
and very briefly you were telling me
that it's now
more
uh people who are struggling with their
food shop and their energy bills as
opposed to
homeless people which you were seeing uh
more individuals who
were without homes before
the war in ukraine before uh the bills
went up um and
how
how has this time period been for those
individuals that you meet here every day
it's quite difficult for them it's quite
challenging
they complain to us that they have so
many children and their family is you
know of xyz and you know um so so many
numbers and um they come for not just
one or two sandwiches they may want four
or six and they also want bread and we
also give them all the food stuff that
we have as well brilliant reverend
adjourney thank you so much and it's
fantastic work that you guys are doing
here at the church now we don't know the
details as of yet what uh liz truss's
package will look like but what we do
know for sure is that places like this
are only going to get busier
all right sabbah for now thank you so
much
now police in canada say that the final
suspect in the mass stabbings in
saskatchewan has died while in police
custody after officers forced his
vehicle from the road mars sanderson was
found near to the town of roster four
days after a series of stabbings which
left 10 people dead and 18 injured our
u.s correspondent martha kelner reports
by the side of a motorway in a remote
corner of canada the moment four days of
terror came to a dramatic end
inside the white truck is miles
sanderson suspected of involvement in
one of canada's worst ever mass murders
hours later he died while in police
custody
the search for clues and for a motive
had centered on this indigenous
community at james smith cree nation
where most of the ten murders took place
this evening our province is breathing a
collective sigh of relief as miles
sanderson is no longer at large
i can confirm that he is no longer a
threat and there is no risk to the
public related to this investigation
before this week few on this reserve
ever locked their doors let alone
imagined that this horror could be
visited upon them
now they're counting their dead
10 people stabbed to death aged between
23 and 78 including gloria burns a drug
addiction counselor and lana head a 49
year old mother of two
sanderson's brother damian also a
suspect in the murders had been found
dead in a field with stab wounds
over 160 officers hunted for 32 year old
miles sanderson who went into medical
distress after his arrest
this community is paying respects to
those who were killed
the danger is now over but the sense of
loss will endure and with the death of
the sanderson brothers any chance of
answers is gone too martha kellner sky
news
now the foreign minister of ukraine has
said that the body of a british aid
worker who was captured by
russian-backed separatists has been
returned with signs of possible
unspeakable torture
paul uri died in july after he was
charged with committing mercenary
activities in the self-proclaimed the
next people's republic in the east of
ukraine a foreign office spokesperson
said reports of the torture of the 45
year old who's from warrington were
disturbing and that it was essential
that they see the results of a full
post-mortem
and sticking with the war in ukraine
president vladimir zelinsky has said
that his forces are making headway in
their counter-offensive against russian
forces in the northeast now later this
morning the defense secretary ben
wallace will meet his allied
counterparts in germany to discuss the
war so let's bring in our security and
defense editor deborah haynes joining us
now from odessa in ukraine debra good
morning to you so plenty to talk about
with the situation in ukraine right now
let's first start with uh paul uria and
what we understand
may have happened to him
the foreign minister who yesterday
tweeted
had been returned of poor yuri and it
showed signs of possible unspeakable
torture his mother has since spoken out
talking about how this um this murderers
uh attacked her son and uh the reuters
news agency is reporting that the
russian ambassador to the uk has been
summoned
what's happened to
and the new prime minister has also
expressed um shock about uh these claims
russian forces have been accused of
unfortunately torturing
not just prisoners but also civilians uh
during this war so it will be very
important
exactly
it's a shame there uh deborah we'll
we'll come back to you when we can
establish a better sound connection i
mean you're in warzone after all but i
do appreciate you for that
i'll come back to you later now let's
take a look at some of today's other
headlines now and health bosses are
warning that the coming winter will be
the busiest on record for the national
health service in a letter to the new
government they say that staff shortages
and rising energy bills will add
considerable pressure to an already
stretched service they say the urgent
action is needed to help with front-line
workers
the police watchdog has confirmed that
no firearm was found at the scene where
a man was shot dead by armed officers in
south london on monday chris cabba was
24 his family have called for an
immediate criminal investigation into
the conduct of the officers involved in
his killing in a statement they said if
chris had not been black he would have
been arrested on monday and not had his
life cut short
now the queen has postponed her privy
council meeting after doctors advised
her to rest the 96 year old monarch will
remain at balmoral in scotland where she
appointed liz trust as the new prime
minister on tuesday the palace has
previously said that the queen has
ongoing mobility issues
a medicine for menopausal women is going
to be sold without the need for a
prescription for the first time in the
uk the hormone replacement therapy will
be available at pharmacies women who are
50 and over and who haven't had a period
in at least a year will be able to get
it
and a possible link between artificial
sweeteners and heart disease has been
found by scientists the study published
in the british medical journal advisors
against considering sweetness healthy
alternatives to sugar after examining
100 000 adults in france
and experts say that a malaria vaccine
developed by scientists at the
university of oxford could contribute
towards dramatically reducing the number
of children who died from the infection
initial trials found it had an 80
efficacy rate
now two princess and a princess have
started at their new school george louie
and charlotte there they are were
accompanied by their parents to duke and
duchess of cambridge on their first day
at lambert school near windsor
four-year-old prince louis is starting
school for the first time joining his
big bro and his big sister the family
recently moved from kensington palace
and now live on the estate at bunza
sure that will be fine all right let's
take a look at what the weather has in
store
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
low pressure is keeping things unsettled
with strong winds at times and spells of
heavy and thundery rain it'll be fairly
mild at first today but for many it'll
be fine but there will be for some heavy
showers around mainly over eastern
scotland and the south northern parts
can expect some fog while the far north
will be dull
and damp
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the premiere for the new movie
tickets to paradise was held in
leicester square last night and the
a-list actors who starred it were in
attendance it's directed by old parker
and is a rom-com about two badly behaved
people
well the stars spoke to our
entertainment correspondent katie
spencer about the film and their advice
for the uk's new prime minister
i thought of this as a drama i thought
this was really trying to depict some of
the horrible things that are going on
around the world do you have any advice
for our new prime minister it's a bit of
a gear well is isn't it day one yep so
well we as
as we always say you wish the best
because there's a lot of things coming
up a lot of a lot of big issues coming
out a lot of
uh financial worries for the the whole
country so we all hope that she does her
best and we hope that there's uh some
great luck in it because it's a it's a
tough time for everybody this is no
women to be terribly clever don't we
george
our top stories this morning the prime
minister is set to announce her plans to
help households and businesses with
soaring energy costs
police in canada have confirmed the
final suspect in the recent mass
stabbings has died after officers rammed
his car off the road
ukraine's foreign minister has said that
the body of a british aid worker who was
captured by russian-backed separatists
has been returned with signs of torture
[Music]
now the new secretary of state for
leveling up housing and communities has
insisted this morning that the
government can't tax its way to growth
looking ahead to the pm's announcements
today to tackle the energy crisis simon
clark rejected the idea of an increase
in the windfall tax on oil and gas
companies and said that the uk needs to
get much closer to energy
self-sufficiency
the prime minister is rightly clear that
we cannot keep on with the mindset that
we can tax our way to growth we can't
keep doing that
we need these oil and gas companies to
be focusing on more extraction an
extraction of north sea gas is up 26
compared to this time last year which is
fantastic we need to see a lot more of
that because the reality is energy
independence is the lasting solution to
the situation we are in there's a lot of
money that could be got from taxing
these oil and gas companies more and
you're deciding the government is
deciding to put all that money onto the
country's credit card there was a time
when that was seen as fiscally
responsible the conservative government
said that was fiscally why now is it
what we do is we is we fix the roof when
the sun is shining the sun is
conspicuously not shining right now this
is a global storm and the uk is uh you
know like the rest of the west having to
react to events which are you know not
of our making
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent amanda aka joining us from
downing street good morning to you
amanda so simon clark they're basically
saying this is all part of a big plan
from austerity years up to now that this
was to make sure that the government had
the money should a huge emergency
confront them
well yes and after a summer of fear
where households up and down the country
have struggled to work out how they
could possibly afford to pay average
bills going up to three and a half
thousand pounds in october maybe five
thousand pounds in the new year finally
the government is responding and for his
trust in only the second full day of her
premiership this really is a defining
moment we're anticipating the cost of
this big package of support could be
more than a hundred billion pounds paid
for as you say by borrowing a real brief
kind of break with the economic
orthodoxy of recent years and indeed
also involving a freeze on energy bills
something which earlier on in the
campaign when it was proposed this trust
was quite dismissive of um as we heard
from simon clark there there though he
said the magnitude of the situation
means they basically have no choice but
to act he said this was a difficult bold
and brave decision now we're going to be
getting more details in parliament
around 11 30 about how exactly this can
work but i think as we heard from the
secretary of state there the team are
really trying to
couch this in the terms of the
geopolitical context of the war
in ukraine and the pressure on gas
prices caused by russians actions there
and really trying to
say well this is the short-term solution
to help people this winter but in the
long term we need to work on our energy
security
i think that will mean looking at
freeing up
the rules around fracking potentially
more licenses to drill in the north sea
all of that also very controversial and
i think overall while there is broad
consensus that urgent big major action
is needed on this there is real unease
particularly in her own party about the
approach they're taking we've had a
summer of warnings from rishi sunak and
his team about the inflationary impact
of borrowing we know the pound has
plummeted to its lowest levels since the
80s a real indicator of the huge
challenge ahead
okay amanda in
downing street for now thank you
now businesses around the country will
be watching today's announcement very
closely with many reporting that their
energy bills have doubled tripled or
shot up even further a new research from
the federation for small business has
found almost all small firms are
concerned about the steep rising costs
well joining me now is their national
chair martin mctake good morning marcin
thanks for coming in with us um so what
do you want to hear from the uh prime
minister today well we're looking for a
package that matches the scale of the
problem i mean i've been in business for
35 years and this is about as bad as
i've ever seen it there are businesses
literally hanging on by their
fingernails you know the cash is running
out they know that in october something
like 60 percent of businesses are faced
with renewing their energy contracts and
for many of them that will be a
disastrous new contract and and the
urgency of this can't be overstated it's
worth reminding um our viewers that
businesses don't have that price cap is
that something that you want to see i
mean is that a place to start by
bringing in a price cap for businesses
in effect what we're hoping we'll see is
that um the price per unit of the energy
will be fixed
and that any of the shortfall will then
be picked up by government borrowing
right go and that that's my next
question then really you're happy with
this idea of going forward simon clark
says that it's okay to do that because
um
we'll sort that out later we've worked
on this is part of the strategy and this
is an extraordinary time yeah i mean
you've only got to look at the fact that
the government effectively borrowed 200
billion to get us through the covet
crisis
it saved countless
jobs and businesses
the idea of letting those businesses go
under when faced by the aggression of
putin seems ridiculous you know there
are 16 million people depend on small
businesses for their livelihood we
cannot allow that to fail
i mean talk us through then some of
these businesses and what they're
telling you how concerned they are that
they could go to the wall if there isn't
loads of help there's loads of examples
i mean there there is an example the
other day of uh i mean the one that
struck me as strange was a pizza shop
who was saying that they were faced with
energy bills which meant they were going
to have to pass on
if they passed on the price to their
customers it would be 25 pounds of pizza
now we know that's not possible his only
alternative was to shut the place down
and in many other cases business owners
are taking the decision either to
mothball or shut their businesses i mean
what difference do you think that the
scrapping of the raise rise in
corporation taxes is going to make for
businesses that's not a major problem
for most small businesses most small
businesses don't mind paying tax on
profits what they resent is paying taxes
on things that they have to have before
they even open the doors so national
insurance was a classic example and
business rates would be another so
there's encouraging signs from the prime
minister that she takes those issues
seriously and she's going to correct
them now there is some reporting that
you might not actually get all the
details of the business package today i
mean that's gonna leave many businesses
still quite uncertain isn't it yes it is
and it's a worrying time i mean
literally uh there are only a few weeks
left before they're going to be faced
with these
uh essentially break
uh make or break contracts so i think um
the government does recognize the
importance of acting quickly and i
honestly hope it's quicker i mean
they're saying is there going to be some
kind of complication with businesses
because obviously small businesses are
one thing i guess is judging the number
what is it profits turnover the number
of staff that you just usually the
number of staff right so but some small
businesses i guess would be quite energy
intensive so there's going to have to be
a some quite clever work done here to
make sure that this is equally
distributed right yeah it's going to be
complex but the biggest divide in this
is that bigger businesses can hedge they
can buy forward and that isn't an offer
or available to small businesses so what
we're talking about here is helping
those vulnerable small businesses that
are not able to hedge and find a way
that can keep them keep them alive it
sounds like you're saying specifically
for businesses with under a head count
for like 25
50 to have a specific package in place
and larger businesses are different kind
of help normally the threshold is about
50. when they when they offer packages
of this type it normally applies to
businesses under 50. but small
businesses are defined as businesses
under 250.
so that they're that's where this target
should be aimed right and that's
obviously a big difference isn't it
in terms of the help that might well be
needed yep all right let me take do
appreciate your time hopefully
businesses will hear something today but
it might be a couple of days appreciate
you coming thank you
now the liberal democrats are warning
that people living in rural areas are
set to be hit the hardest by the rising
cost of energy bills and the party's
calling on the government to provide
additional support for those living in
the countryside well let's bring in now
the party's rural affairs spokesperson
tim farron for more on this good morning
to you tim fran thank you for being with
us um so just tell us
what is the concern that people living
in rural areas have about dealing with
their energy prices right now
well there's something like 20 000
people just in cumbria alone and tens of
thousands more in the west country in
northumberland other parts of the uk who
are off mains gas and many people won't
realize that there is no energy price
cap at all uh for those those businesses
and for those homes so in cumbria it is
reckoned that even with the
rising price cap if that was to continue
that your average household on off mains
gas on uh liquid uh fuel would be maybe
a thousand to two thousand pounds a year
worse off even than the worst off uh
household on mains gas so to bring those
homes into the
the tent of protection so to speak uh in
the first place and then to make sure
that the cap is set no higher than for
those uh majority of people in this
country who are on the mains
yeah and what gives you the sense that
the government won't do that i mean
there was a question that asked in them
pmq just said by victoria actions on
exactly this topic to make sure that the
countryside rural communities are not
forgotten
well maybe they will but there has of
course been a pattern over the last few
years of the conservative government
taking rural communities for granted
whether it be over sewage being dumped
into our lakes or the cuts to farm
payments or the simple underfunding of
for example gp surgeries in communities
like mine so they would be following a
pattern if they chose not to intervene
today to help rural communities that are
off the mains but they might i'll be
very very much at the first at the front
of the queue to welcome it if they do
obviously one of the major concerns for
us is that has an impact on businesses
many people in rural communities aren't
just living in their homes but they're
working from their homes whether it's in
farming or hospitality tourism or other
parts of the economy so this has a huge
impact on people's ability to make a
living to create jobs for others as well
as just to keep themselves and their
families warm and to run a home
mr ferran you will have seen the
reporting about what may be in this
package of measures to help um homes and
businesses
what is your feeling as to as to how
substantial that package is going to be
and your thoughts on how it should be
paid for
yeah well i don't think we should be
slagging it off before it's out in terms
of the content because we don't know
what's in it uh obviously i'm pushing
for uh particularly rural communities to
be supported through it and i will be
very positive if they do and critical if
they don't but it obviously has to be a
comprehensive package it has to make
sure that people are not paying any more
than they currently are and to ensure
that businesses are supported as well
because the one economic figure at the
moment that isn't terrible is
unemployment but i'm already seeing
businesses in my community uh closing or
facing closure largely because the
conservative government has been on
holiday for the last three months and
not doing anything about it and any
action today will be too late for many
of those businesses and how should it be
paid for well look either profit is a
good thing if it's used properly but
there's no doubt whatsoever that if liz
trust chooses to borrow against our
children's future and risk the economy
and the well-being of our country in the
future when instead she could have paid
for this by taxing the unnecessary
unexpected inflated profits of the
energy companies and she'll not only put
herself on the side of the wealthiest
against the majority of the people in
this country she'll also have marked
herself out as being economically
illiterate and risking the country's
future
economically illiterate now
you were quoted in the newspaper this
weekend mr farren as saying you blame
yourself
for liz trust being the conservative
party is that right
uh tongue-in-cheek but um it depends how
long you've got but uh it is well known
this trust was a member of the liberal
democrats in the 90s people allowed to
change their mind but if i could make it
as succinct as possible in 1994 as a 24
year old
i had been
a lib dem parliamentary candidate for a
totally unwinnable seat in the previous
election 92 alongside theresa may you
may remember
and so i gave a briefing in 94 to about
30 or 40 young lib dems or lib dem
students about how they might go about
you know becoming a parliamentary
candidate at subsequent elections um and
i i made a joke at that time and it was
a joke honestly that
that was a good time to join the tory
party because for a career if that was
all you're interested in because the
tories were in such a terrible state
facing an annihilation at the coming
general election i said well you know if
all you were bothered about was holding
high office then you'd join the tories
now because by the time they're
recovered in 10 or 15 years time you'd
be well set there is i would say an 80
chance that liz trust was in that room
at that time so she may have heard me
and as you say this might all be my
fault
tim ferran the
uh mp and the liberal german swimsuit
the rural affairs we appreciate your
time this morning thank you very much
you're welcome
all right still to come on the program
i'll be speaking to the campaign group
don't pay uk to ask whether the prime
minister's energy plans will go far
enough to help people struggling with
soaring bills
[Music]
welcome back more now on our top story
this morning with the prime minister
expected to unveil a major package to
help
with soaring energy bills there's a
campaign group called don't pay uk which
has been calling for people to boycott
paying their bills all together from
october unless they're cut to an
affordable level so all the pm's plans
set out today be enough
let's bring in one of the group's
organizers lewis ford who joins us now
live lewis ford good morning to you and
thanks for being with us so what kind of
level would bills need to be cut to for
don't pay uk to say that'll be right and
for them to then pay their bills
um so we're calling for 2021 levels so
back to april of last year before our 54
increase
okay so it's probably not going to get
near that is it
it doesn't look like at the moment um i
think
looking about two and a half grand so
you know fuel properties classes 10 of
your household income
uh
so yeah average income 25 grand so we're
still looking at you know a lot of
people are going to be completely unable
to afford this you know we've got a lot
of people in fuel poverty already with
the current prices so
yeah we're still going to see a lot of
people struggling from this i think
and you'll still be campaigning then at
that point after we hear the
announcement today for people not to pay
their bills come the 1st of october um
it's looking that way if the if the
announcements that have been have been
rumored are coming then yeah i think so
um and you know we're not just
campaigning to stop paying bills we're
also building up local community support
networks things like mutual aid in order
to help people this winter who are going
to go
without energy and who are going to
struggle
i'll come on to a bit of that work in a
moment but let me just get this right
we're still at the threshold that you
guys are waiting for for a million
people to join the campaign before you
say don't pay your
bills yeah so the most important thing
for us really is the number rather than
the date so
you know we know that 200 000 people so
far have you know we've been heard you
know these these demands have
drawn the attention of this government
and
you know things are being done so we
think with a million people the you know
the pressure that would apply we'd be
able to get to these you know more
affordable levels
yeah i mean it's the first time that
i've been able to speak to you guys
does it feel like people have stopped
joining up to this or are you happy with
the numbers that are still joining up to
the campaign
um we had 25 000 people sign up on
tuesday uh so you know we're we're still
seeing
we're still seeing the number going up i
mean i've got the ticker open on my
other on my other screen i can still see
people joining as we speak
i mean but you know the dangers of
people not paying their bills don't you
you know they'll be cut off and they
could end up um being put onto what
for many will be a punitive uh pre-pay
meter
yeah i think that's the point isn't it
you know people are on pre-payment
meters and the people that typically on
these prepayment meetings are those who
have been unable to afford their bills
and yet they're put on excuse me they're
put on a tariff that's more expensive
than
you know your typical tariffs and then
if they can't pay
they get cut off no matter no matter the
situation you know
with
i suppose you're more traditional
payment plan you can negotiate with your
with your provider when you can't afford
and they don't you know they don't cut
you off whereas you know prepare me is a
punishment really aren't they for not
paying your bill
well it's a little bit more expensive
for people when they're on those
prepayment meters um
lewis just tell us about your situation
what what led you to to join this
movement and not just join it but be a
regional organizer
yeah i think it was just a accumulation
of
just
seeing my you know seeing my wage gets
squeezed and you know every time i felt
like i was doing better there was just
something behind me you know i i'd get a
pay rise the prices go up you know we
saw our shopping bill you know i've got
two young children um you know
we see our our bills go up each month
you know we do a food shop and then we
do the same food shop the next month and
it's more expensive and then you know
we're paying 350 pounds for our energy
bills since april and yet they're now
saying that we want us to pay 550 pounds
and if we do that then we're still going
to be in debt next year so
you know i saw the don't pay
campaign via social media and it was
spoken about and i just looked into it
and it you know
a collective action a collective
movement like this feels like the the
only way we can really
make this kind of change it's the only
way we can get listened to individually
we don't have
the power that we probably should have
in in this kind of democracy but you
know together we can actually do
something
and lose i would never tell you how to
live your life but i mean there are
other ways i guess to save money in the
household aren't there have you thought
and i guess you've been through all of
those things
we've we've done everything i mean with
octopus energy and they've been quite
good at kind of sending us tips on how
to on how to save energy you know
it's
we've been doing
anything we can really you know reducing
the amount of washing we do you know not
using the tumble dryer
there's all
there's all kinds of like little things
you can do you know
jumpers on during the house you know
we've not even seen the full effect of
of what this is going to be like yet
because you know we've had quite a warm
warm summer and our energy usage is
still at nearly 200 nearly 200 pounds
with all these little savings
so yeah i'm i'm a little bit worried for
winter and what that's going to bring
and you've got a family lewis as well
yeah
yeah yeah two young children just about
to get ready to do the school run second
day back
all right well i wish you all the best
lewis all right um thank you a regional
organizer from uh don't pay uk thank you
all right let's take a look at what the
weather has in store
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now low pressure is keeping things
unsettled with strong winds at times and
spells of heavy rain some of which will
be thundery it is fairly mild at first
today but it'll be fine for many but
there'll be heavy showers around mainly
over eastern scotland and the windy
south northern parts can expect to see
some fog while the far north will be
dull and a little bit damp
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
now i'm looking forward to showing you
these all morning president obama the
former president of the united states
has had a portrait done he went to the
white house for is he was there for a
short period of time not as long as some
of his supporters would have liked but
here's the moment him and michelle
unveils their portraits
and they
are pretty good i mean obama's one is
like photo realistic it's fantastic
michelle's she looks wonderful as always
and as you can see the obama's there
giving them the claps he looks quite
impressive doesn't he